c'est une commune ouverte sur la plaine
de versailles un territoire partagé
entre la campagne et la ville plaisir s
et 31 mille habitants ont rejoint la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en 2016 ce
territoire essaie de trouver un
équilibre entre urbanisation et zones
naturelles le pôle commercial va
s'agrandir cette année avec l'ouverture
d'open sky et des emplois pour les
plaisirs oies à la clé l'urbanisation
c'est la réhabilitation du centre bourg
et la rénovation du quartier du val
hibou l'investissement de 65 millions
d'euros un projet déjà engagé que devra
poursuivre le prochain maire de la ville
avec une prise en compte plus globale de
ce quartier touché par la délinquance
les questions sociales et l'emploi des
aménagements environnementaux sont aussi
prévues dans ce futur écoquartier
l'environnement est aussi une
préoccupation plaisir compte une forêt
plusieurs parcs naturels la question des
transports et de la circulation sera
posée notamment après l'aménagement de
la rd 30 et de la passerelle plaisir et
l'encours le phénomène de désert médical
plane au dessus de plaisir une ville
classée en zone d'action complémentaire
par l' agence régionale de santé
ils sont quatre médecins pour 10000
habitants 2017 selon les derniers
chiffres de l'ue rps il y avait quatorze
médecins généralistes ils sont âgés de
50 ans en moyenne